[Music]
invented in the middle of the 20th
century instant film made photographic
images materialize almost magically the
picture appeared in minutes no more
waiting for days for film to be
processed today it's a digital world but
instant film is still getting plenty of
exposure
with instant film you can watch an image
develop before your very eyes
no film lab or digital printer necessary
just say cheese and wait to see what
develops
many decades after its invention instant
photo development still seems like a
neat trick
making the magic happen is a many
layered process one that involves
multiple materials and chemicals
production begins with the film negative
it takes place in the dark to prevent
pre-exposure
the technician dons night vision goggles
allowing him to monitor plastic film as
it unwinds into a coating machine
inside various dyes and chemicals will
transform the film into a negative
they switch the lights back on briefly
for our camera
the film travels up and down towards the
coating machine
it's a system that prevents any
slackening in the feed
the coating is also done in the dark so
this worker demonstrates the process for
our camera on a small research machine
liquid photo chemicals and dyes flow
onto the surface of the plastic film
he spreads the liquids across the film
for an even application
this is all done mechanically inside the
real coating machine
once coated the film will head into the
dryer
the various coatings will dry in
separate layers without intermingling
here's a test tube lineup of the liquid
components of the negative
the colorful ones are dyes and the white
ones are other chemicals
they apply black backing to the negative
to block light again preventing
pre-exposure
the trip through the dryer is 87 yards
long hot air dries the chemicals on the
surface of the film once again it all
happens in the dark to protect the light
sensitive film
coiled up and packed into light tight
drums the color negative material is now
on its way to a second factory to be
assembled into the instant film pack
upon arrival they thread the negative
onto a machine along with other
materials for the film pack they include
a plastic-based material called the mask
and the positive paper that receives the
photographic image from the negative
the various materials are steered toward
assembly stations by a system of rollers
here's a lineup of the various materials
to be assembled that's the mask on the
far left and the negative in the middle
the negative heads towards a series of
hot presses one press laminates a
plastic spacer called the rail to the
negative
another lamination head applies the mask
to the positive sheet that will receive
the image
on a different machine equipment folds a
kind of foil pouch and injects it with
film developer
here's an inside look at the pouch the
blue liquid is the developer
encased in the foil lined envelope it
will stay fresh until needed
back on the main assembly machine
another hot press laminates the
developer pouch to the other film
materials
this completes the film sandwich and it
heads into another station to be sliced
into photo sized pieces
the photo frames ride a wheel with a
counter that divides them into stacks of
eight
meanwhile robot arms deposit a
rectangular spring on a battery then
they position the eight pictures on the
spring battery assembly followed by a
light blocking cover
the stack then moves forward to be
squeezed into a plastic cassette
a suction type of device now picks up a
cardboard box and transfers it to the
end of the film pack line
another device captures the film pack as
it comes off the line and places it in
the cardboard box
once folded closed the box of instant
film rides the carousel to a scale
a quick weighing confirms there's enough
film in the box so it's ready to ship
the assembly of this instant film pack
has taken roughly three minutes
now those instant memories are just a
few clicks away
[Music]
you